all right yeah yes
hey I in the house it's Barbie why is
that how did I do oh now the game is the
wrong size what what you doing hang on
what's happening what's happening mark
am I missing it what happened what'd I
miss
you're fine you're fine have you guys
just give me the whole time and I have
not been able to blow you - good good -
come back look I knew you were busy okay
I'm just giving you a break thank you
thank you're welcome thank you you're
welcome thank you
I can't believe of all the bots what do
you mean of all the BOTS of course it's
gonna be this lot Barbara she's the best
all right I got you it was my friendly I
do one more thing because it's bugging
me okay all right no [ __ ] marks for
serious now me I have hits gamer mode
baby bread yeah get miss bread
oh man that's so mean getting it out
relax I'm you make the calls I don't
know what happens went good reference
Bob I don't know what happens thanks
when you play una without us but Barbara
has never been evil when not me I didn't
do wait you gotta win not playing to
lose playing to win playing to win and
playin - you know Bob she's gonna do Bob
let me ask you did Barbara Plus for him
because I didn't see it now he's lying
he's just creating manufacturing haha
never see this coming
[Laughter]
I do have a slight situation with my
scarred mmm and what's that it's not
yellow oh look see wait I had no choice
in the matter it just is what does what
it does
that's phenom I see but you you you
create these stories about Barbara to be
to be angry but then that then you you
just let me get away with stuff you had
to draw Barbara plus for me she didn't
even remember what this one does a copy
copy ha ha I'll save you you're just
manufacturing the situation with Barbara
you're you're crafting this wade if you
think about it the entire game is a
computer program therefore it's all a
bot but ok alway do you want to inflict
some pain on Barbara there you go buddy
well yeah you should definitely inflict
some pain on Barbara I think right there
we go
I don't ki dokey you just leave that
read for you there buddy what to do yeah
that's the spirit I just say something
to one of those I feel like you really
have yeah
wow you guys there's just a stack of
draw to is ready for me to draw look at
that play from Barbara green good stuff
never mind we'll give her another turn
sir game mode that's just oops all twos
and it's nothing but how fast can you
click
well I believe that's look at what why
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's very sad you skip that Barbara
Barbara has to draw more uh well okay I
that's my but that's my fault yeah mark
did that to you listen wait it you're
gonna draw some some powerful cards yeah
I'm just gonna do it
she's got nothing but red and yellow
great you're gonna draw some powerful
cards get her yeah the right color and
everything now get her ha right nothing
can stop me now
well awkward there we go what me
celebrating yeah
that's just so happy I Mark didn't plus
to me all game nor was he Barbara yeah
true but I still appreciate him not this
is balls I got something for you right
here let's just get this for first job I
just want you to know I don't have a
choice
so do it to me come on to do do it do me
daddy I'm sorry
yeah choice challenger he's got a choice
I had me the cards oh you're so bone are
we are we
that is I look Wade I listen look man
what you want to play a game sure yeah
let's play a game
all right cool what's the game what am i
doing I don't know whatever you want
I'm just playing it it's called who no
second ago how about that oh yes I
didn't want to wait no wait do you have
plus twos one we're doing this okay okay
all those cards I'm sorry
oh you have a plus two nearly died there
stick skips back to back I don't
remember
has at all I hope it's not green hey I
never win agent I don't know what you're
doing the team up was bobba bobba Oh
kiss Bob opera ha ha I wasn't teaming I
was trying to team with Wade okay the
heart of the cards didn't suck at
teaming that's like you punched your
teammate in the dick wait I don't think
you can team in this game celebration
that was cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah keep it go Jesus tents gifts
between me and don't you don't [ __ ] me
forget it oh not really boy hey look at
the teamwork reverse back different
colors I couldn't blue
I would blue you mark I would have blue
you that's okay hey listen okay thank
you you think I can do anything I've got
numbers that's it you want numbers I've
got numbers oh I had the lowest about a
card Lee moaning about here right I'd
like to think that someday we'll realize
that god that's [ __ ] she had a green
zero she could have played is it
[ __ ] yes
[Music]
Bob take her head is there a green zero
in there no there's a yellow zero yeah
but she could have played that there was
a zero and she didn't play a zero why
does that count
why don't you know the rules this deep
way this is entirely no she yes it's
okay I'm gonna play a nine yeah it was
Barbara though she played her own card
she was on I feel sick
I'm not a liar she had a zero because I
had the zero then the C relaxes it was
her zero though and it was my zero
before she's got red green and yellow
there's a green zero the challenge only
counts same color not same number why
after person who's won almost 200 games
call mr. Ubisoft I want to talk to him
on the phone I don't think that's how
that works you know mr. Hasbro
production whom I don't know who's the
maker brothers don't know man hey you
can help you can do this
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay this is it you're the one who chose
not to play or plug you don't worry wait
I'll fix it oh wait come on I know
there's like six seven out on the field
I know there's so many sevens in the
wild and they're not getting played you
know what wait for you suddenly just
authority cactus dildo up my ass you
have four cards for now this this is
gonna this is gonna happen I just want
everyone to know you know that's not the
outcome I expected
yeah that's not what I would have
thought she would do and that's it you
and I don't have any cards over there
good for you wait are you gonna find
something to complain about [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
you know what I really thought I was
helping you I don't know what you want
from me does this help
I guess I don't understand how reverses
work okay Wade doesn't understand how
this game works either
don't worry Wade if it gets to me I've
got a card that will solve all your
problems
well don't worry
sevens are dealt with we've done it well
now Wade gets to be the one hey wait now
you done I'm feel good mark those cards
hey what's up no hey I'll give you mine
then no never gonna end
all right you're right the first time
bleed diplomatic dick dick dick
incredibly dickish then work good her
daughter go on get her oh god damn it
get her come do Oh No
okay that's fine oh alright wait I know
you have one of these in your hand
[ __ ] oh no do you not oh dang it
I just try to team and team up with you
mmm yeah normally there's some
discussion before the team up I will
give the games first decline never never
decline
scrub declining all that small peepee
energy yeah we only take big [ __ ] here
[Music]
- oh dear oh wow
Barbara your hand sucks or does it oh it
sucks okay oh I couldn't just someone
completely under my arm I know you have
one of these in your in your stack of
cards right please
total of a [ __ ] kind I was being sincere
uh Wow we all chill we all chill
everybody chill chill chill him wait
what color you want Oh blue I'm sorry I
should have waited for you he really did
want flu I assumed I would lie to me
anyway Oh whose turn is it okay well
it's
why are you this way ah [ __ ]
oh wow what a draw
you're not gonna celebrate when you draw
a draw for what on your first pole when
you have a wall boy Wow
man Barbara is really good at this very
good that's best that was okay well all
right mm-hmm
hey sorry Bob unless you can do
something or not what the [ __ ] I was
pretty sure you were gonna have one of
those on your hand I've got [ __ ] Pete
oh you didn't see you didn't see the the
+8 you okay okay cool checking I wanted
to remind o dear for that oh no oh it's
mine now oh I have it okay you okay yeah
a couple of them all right that's not
cool
yellow it up sure dude
thanks man come on dude why is that what
you wanted to happen I don't want
Barbara I only have two cards another
money make it five hours I'll bring it
up man don't you worry
all right things only get girthier when
they're in my hands I just mark I want
mark well okay baby here's the girth
earning
all right yellows great okay all right
nice and Pato I'm not gonna lie I was
not paying attention I didn't see a
single thing of what
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay we're like those back sir well I'm
just gonna do this to see what happens
then I guess you went to a Barbara
Barbara I challenge you yeah very
good-looking too I have a smash into
this problem who is it that's one of the
he's chubbo taking some of my cards
friends appreciate that yeah Barbara got
four back didn't see him
she sure did get four yeah mistake sorry
huh
I hate all of you ha hate me more that's
not good that's not good at all anyone
know what Barbara's got nope nope well
risk it for the biscuit I'll risk it for
my biscuit
[Music]
[Laughter]
risk it for the biscuit I drew it oops
hey or not oops its nukes oh look I was
trying to set up an epic Barbara dunk
oh yes that's the good stuff
yeah all right to the beginning of the
game or more like oh yeah let's do it
baby no no no let's do it to it how like
I don't get it that's three times in a
single set that happens I don't like red
very much can you make it I don't I
don't like red either yeah sure that was
going to wait that's a good color it's a
good color right there that's good cuz
like a mistake but I guess I'm gonna do
this bad boy okay thanks man hmm it's
all right it's all right
interesting interesting it's all right
everything's fine
hate to see oh man I don't have any
blues no gosh darn it oh wow yeah hate
to see it you you hate to see can't you
can't let you I didn't actually have it
was sincerely out of that man you got a
lot of cards Wade my name is Barbara oh
really
I got nothing come on now hmm
interesting in that seven in there and
that's a fun one but alright Bob you
this also is totally legit cream maybe
those challenge cards give them to me my
god now he's got blues one green you've
got many colors we're all on the inside
boom oh yeah yeah okay how about that
yeah me me me remark I think you know
the play mark yeah did you know I what's
the play what's black mark you know the
play make the play mark it's all on you
buddy what's the play I don't know the
play I don't make the play mark what
copy do you have what Edition is this
the play look at that oh great made the
play made the play guys you made the
play you're al your start it makes
horrible l you make the play I'm about
to here's the play do it Bob way to
might have said it that's not what I
thought you spiked it thank you thank
you challenge me well she didn't it's
over what color you want
[Music]
interesting interesting very interesting
I'll as that is very interesting this
yeah take that yeah yeah yeah play you
made the play I made the play leave this
in the hands of oh wow you have a choice
to make miney moe catch the I want a
hurry on this move Wow Wow
[Music]